- Oh-oh, what's happening?
- You have been selected.
(bell ringing)
- Maybe embody Steve Irwin,
get something going in there.
- (off-mic) Steve Irwin.
- Just mimic me.
- That won't be possible.
- Nope.
Nope nope. (laughing)
- Damn, really?
- Gonna do so bad!
- Can I practice by myself and come back?
I'm just gonna wheel over here and...
- He needs some time alone.
- Here goes.
- Hi, everybody. (giggle)
- It's really hard, the Australian accent.
- Oi.
Australia.
Yeah.
- Shrimp on the barbie. (snicker)
- Good day, mate.
- G'day mate.
- You're supposed to make
sound like "Good eye, mate".
G'day mate.
- G'day mate.
- My name's Caitlin.
- My name's Mike.
- I'm from Sydney, Australia.
- Who's going surfing?
- I'm terrible at this accent.
- So in Mad Max, they talk like this.
- Hope you don't mind if I
borrow your car for a weekend?
- There's a British woman who works here,
and I can hear that it's
messing up my Australian.
So I have to, like.
- Don't blame her.
- I wish all Australians were like Tanya.
- You guys say "Nao" so weird,
you guys put other vowels in
there beside just the 'o'.
- No.
- Nao.
- [Man] Just say no.
- [Host] No.
- [Man] No!
- [Man] Now!
- I went to the shops the other
day, and bought some beer.
- Okay.
- I went to the shops
and bought some beer.
- I went to the shops the other
day, and bought some beers.
- Aw, (light giggle)
you sound like, pretty
much exactly the same!
- (laughing anxiously)
- I went to the shops,
and bought some beer.
- I went to the shops
and brought some beer.
- I went to the shops the
other day and bought some bear.
- I went to the shops and
(laughs) bought some bear!
What did I do wrong?
Everything?
- I went to the shops the other
day, and bought some beer.
- [Host] Pretty good.
- Thank you.
- [Host] Pretty English.
Pretty good.
- Listen, Australian accent
and English accent, not,
they're not that different!
Right?
- Whoa.
- Oi went to the shops,
and bought some beers.
- Nice, that was the
closest we've come, I'd say.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- No.
You do it, say "no".
- See that, "no".
- [Man] Nose.
- [Host] Nose.
So it's like a 'n - y - o - s - e'.
Nose.
- I've had enough of this discrimination.
- Gabby's all around.